en este vídeo voy a intentar demostrar o
más bien en los próximos vídeos
intentaré demostrar un caso muy especial
del teorema stoxx el el teorema stoxx
para una versión digamos muy especial y
estoy haciendo esto pueda porque su
demostración es un poco más sencilla y
al mismo tiempo es muy convincente en el
caso especial que supondremos es que la
superficie con la que con la que estamos
trabajando es la gráfica de una función
que depende de xy de ye que están en
alguna región r
es decir si me das un punto xy
particular sólo determina un único punto
en esta superficie entonces es un es
como un mapeo de esta región r a la
superficie que ya está en tres
dimensiones así que esta prueba no
aplica superficies como son las esferas
o algo así donde en cada punto se le
pueden asociar a otros dos puntos en el
espacio o algo así pero bueno este es un
muy buen comienzo la otra cosa que que
vamos a suponer es que nuestra función
zeta que que es la altura digamos es una
función de x ideye pero además que tiene
derivadas
segundo orden continuas entonces vamos a
notar eso son derivadas de segundo orden
continuas
continuas ok y eso eso para qué lo
hacemos bueno eso es lo que nos va a
permitir esencialmente es que cuando yo
tomé la derivada de z con respecto de i
y luego tomé su derivada respecto de x
bueno esencialmente esto va a ser la
derivada primero respecto de x y luego
respecto de ella es decir que las
derivadas cruzadas vamos a llamarlo así
sean iguales esto es para lo que vamos a
utilizar que sus derivadas de segundo
orden sean continuas y bueno hablemos un
poquito también de nuestro campo
vectorial porque queremos hacer evaluar
la integral del campo de vectorial a lo
largo de la curva entonces vamos a pedir
que las derivadas parciales de primer
orden de nuestro campo vectorial sean
continuas ok entonces con esto dicho
vamos a ver qué nos dice el teorema de
stocks vamos a tratar de ver cuando es
cierto el teorema de stocks entonces el
teorema stoxx nos dice que la integral d
del campo vectorial punto de r a lo
largo de nuestra curva c aunque de hecho
es una curva cerrada así que le podemos
poner esto cuál es nuestra curva bueno
la voy a estar pintando en azul
esencialmente es esta que es la frontera
de nuestra superficie estamos pensando
en una superficie que está acotada por
esta curva que digamos es suave y las
cosas que ya hemos dicho en otro vídeo
entonces esta integral de línea va a ser
igual a la integral doble que es
esencialmente de superficie
de hecho déjenme ponerlo con este color
va a ser la integral sobre nuestra
superficie s de quien pues va a ser del
rotación al df rotacional de f punto de
ese punto de s
esta es una integral de superficie
entonces
en este vídeo y el próximo vamos a
enfocarnos en desarrollar esta parte de
aquí déjenme mostrarlo la parte de la
derecha vamos a tratar de desarrollar la
parte de la derecha y en los siguientes
vídeos tratar de desarrollar la parte de
la izquierda y ver si coinciden en algún
momento ok entonces para ir empezando
esto vamos a ver quién es el rey
el rotacional df entonces vamos a
calcular el rotacional df que recordemos
que lo podemos ver como el operador
gradiente cruz el campo vectorial qué
significa eso bueno esto en realidad es
un determinante verdad es un
determinante donde tenemos a los
vectores canónicos y al vector canónico
j y al vector canónico cada que lo voy a
hacer con verde
con verde ok tenemos estos vectores y
esto es un determinante que en realidad
es notación recordemos que esto sólo es
notación y luego quién va a ir aquí
bueno pues va a ir el operador gradiente
pero ese ese simplemente es la parcial
respecto de x la parcial respecto de iu
y la parcial respecto de z quien va en
el último renglón pues en los elementos
o las entradas de nuestro campo
vectorial efe que los voy a poner en
azul que es
q quiere que son funciones que dependen
de tres variables x jay-z que están de
hecho acá arriba entonces vamos a
calcular esto quien es esto pues si
empezamos con nuestro vector y el vector
y va a multiplicar a quien pues a la
parcial respecto del de r - la parcial
respecto de z de cv entonces es la
parcial de r respecto de y menos la
parcial de q respecto de z luego va un
menos menos
- j que multiplica a quien vamos a
quitar columna y renglón de jota y nos
queda la parcial de r respecto de x
rx menos la parcial de p respecto de z
parcial de p respecto de zeta
y ahora quien nos queda más
cada vez bueno el vector k por la
parcial de cv respecto dx cupé x menos
la parcial de p
respecto de y entonces este es el
rotacional de f y ahí voy a dejarlo
estoy estoy tratando de hacer vídeos
cada vez más cortos así que en el
próximo vídeo
voy a intentar expresar de ese la
diferencial de ese y luego evaluar este
producto punto para poder así llegar a
la integral de superficie ya después
veremos quién es la integral de f a lo
largo de una curva y veremos que esto en
realidad coincide